حديث وبالبحث عن سر المزاج الحسن في
الصباح وخلال اليوم
فبعد يوم عمل طويل تعود الى المنزل تغير
ملابسك لعادل تنام شوي وفي الصباح تنام
شوي وفي الصباح تستيقظ لتبدا الدوره نفسها
مجددا هذا التعافي والحصول على بسط كاف من
الراحه بعد يوم العمل تعتبر رفاهيه
بالنسبه لكثير من الموظفين
طبعا في هذا السياق دراسه جديده لقياس
تاثير الراحه على المزاج بعد يوم العمل
نشرت في مجله علم النفس المهني والتنظيمي
البريطاني واجريت على 124 موظفا النتائج
وجدت ان الذين استرخوا جيدا بعد يوم العمل
كانوا اكثر هدوءا ويقظا في اليوم التالي
والعكس صحيح الباحثون ينصحون بضروره اعاده
شحن جسدك وعقلك وطاقتك حاول ان تجد وقتا
لممارسه هواياتك
يعني ذلك اي ان لا يكون يوم
ك من الورشه للفرشه يعني والمزيد طبعا وكل
التفاصيل ستكون مع زميلتنا لميس حول كيف
نسترخي بعد الدوام بشكل افضل تفضلي يا
لميس كيف صباح الخير احنا بنخلص هلا وقت
الاجتماع واحنا تعبانين نحن لازم نخلص
حلقه ونروح نرتاح عشان نلحق فكره حلوه
من اجل تجنب الشعور بالارهاق المفرط
والحصول على تعافن جيد بعد العمل ينصح احد
المختصين النفسيين في جامعه السوني بروكا
الامريكيه بعده طرق اولها القيام بانشطه
تساعد على الانفصال ذهنيا عن العمل مثل
ممارسه الهوايات او قضاء الوقت مع احبائك
ومقابله اصدقائك قراءه كتاب او حتى مشاهده
فيلم الانفصال عن العمل يعني ايضا عدم
التحقق من رسائل البريد الالكتروني الخاصه
بالعمل بعد انتهاء وقت الدوام ممارسه
تمارين تامل اليقظه الذهنيه والاسترخاء من
ثلاث الى خمس دقائق على الاقل ويفضل
ممارستها قبل النوم لمساعده العقل والجسم
في الحصول على نوم مريح طيب ماذا نفعل اذا
لم نستطع الالتزام بكل ما سبق لا تزال
هناك بعض الاستراتيجيات لتحسين الحاله
المزاجيه خلال اليوم التالي في العمل
التنفس بعمق مثلا وممارسه تمارين الاطاله
من وقت لاخر اخيرا التفاعل والتواصل مع
زملائك اث ناء فترات الراحه ويفضل ان
تتحرر العمل ونحن سالنا الناس في مصر كيف
تقضي وقتك بعد ساعات العمل نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
بقعد لي ساعه ساعه ونص في الجيم وبعد كده
بروح بقى وبقعد مع ابني مع زوجتي
وبنتلمه ولو انا مثلا في اقدر ازور والدتي
بروح ازورها ما بقدرش يبقى بستنى يوم
الاجازه بتاعتي اتفرج موفي بيلعب بلاي
ستيشن بيحكي اصحابه بهدي شوي بهالموضوع
يعني بحب اكون مع عائلتي الصغيره
دي تعديل مزاجي خالص يعني بعد الغدا ممكن
انزل اتمشى شويه في النادي
بحب اتمشى في النجيله الخضار واليها ريحه
بتفوق ايه الموضوع نفسي مش اكتر من كده
ليه اهتمامات بالجوانب الزراعيه وطلعت كل
ما يدور في في مصر تحديدا في العالم
العربي لاي رياضه عشان يخرج من المود بتاع
الشغل دوت وما يبقاش فيه اي ضغوط عليه ولا
اي مشاكل تبقى ماثره عليه يعني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا مدربه الحياه
ايمان حسن صباح الخير استاذه ايمان اهلا
بك صباح الخير يعني الراحه مهمه
صح ما قلنا شيء لكن كيف من الممكن ان
يرتاح الشخص اذا كان يوم عمل طويل عليه
ضغوط يرجع البيت يحاول يسترخي ولكن ما
يستطيع لانه يفكر بما انجز ولم ينجز
فبالتالي ياتي الى الليل وينام وهو قلق
اخذ لسماع كل اللي عم بفكر فيه طول النهار
حقيقه قبل ما نحكي كيف لازم نعرف اهميه
الموضوع لانه عقلنا اذا بيعرف انه في شيء
مهم فهو راح يوظف له الطاقه ليش الانسان
عم يضل عقله بالشغل لانه يعتقد انه مهم
ويعتقد انه هو مصدر بقائه واستقراره
بالحياه فاحساسه بانه شيء كتير مهم بخليه
يوظف له طاقته طوال الوقت فخلينا ندرك
اهميه انه نسترخي بنفس القدر لاهميه العمل
والتركيز بالعمل حتى نعرف نوظف هذه الطاقه
وهو سؤال كيف مسترخي لانه في ناس مثلا ما
بيحبوا يقعدوا في البيت بيخلصوا يوم عملهم
عشان يشعروا انه هم استفادوا من هذا اليوم
وانجز بيفضلوا خارج البيت
اه لغايه الليل باي اعداد اجتماعيه او ما
شابه هل هذا يعتبر راحه اوكي الحقيقه هو
المقصود بالاسترخاء وبالذات انه ما يعني
الشيء الطاقه اللي هدرتها خلال اليوم ما
كملت هدر فيها المقصود فيها انه انا افصل
عن العمل لانه تبين اذا انه الانسان حاسس
بالتهديد وحاسس بانه لسه هو عليه مسؤوليات
فاللي بصير انه بكون عم بشغل من جهازه
العصبي الجزء المسؤول عن التوتر جهازنا
العصبي جزئين جزء مسؤول عن التوتر اللي
بنسميه الودي والجزء الاخر اللي سميه نظير
الوديه لمسؤول عن حاله انه يسمح لي استرخي
يسمح للخلايا عندي تتجدد ويسمح لي
بالابداع والتشافي فلما يكون الانسان اذا
طلع من شغله راح يتسلى مع اصدقائه
يستمتع فهذا يعتبر استرخاء نفصل من هو
يعمل عمل مكتبي بانه يخلص دوامه ختم اخر
ورقه وسكر الملف وراح وعاش حياته لكن بعض
الاعمال تتطلب من الشخص المتابعه يعني
احنا مثلا في عملنا كاعلام يجب ان نتابع
تويتر الاخبار اولا باول حتى نكون
ابديت محدثين دائما لليوم الثاني ما
نستطيع ان نفصل كيف نفصل هو المهم في
الموضوع انك تعرف انه لو اخذت يعني عشر
دقائق فيها استرخاء فهي بتشتغل على
عشر دقائق رائعه بس هلا بيتوقف الموضوع
على كميه السترس اللي انا حامله في تجربه
اجريت على مجموعه من الاشخاص في احدى
الشركات يلي عندهم طلبوا منهن اثناء العمل
انه كل ساعه يتوقفوا لمده دقيقه اما
يذوقوا شيء لذيذ او يعملوا هذه الحركه
الايدين او يتسابوا فتبين بعد اسبوع انه
ارتفعت المبيعات عندهم وانخفض التوتر
فالقصه هي اللي بدنا نعرفه انه لما
الانسان يكون عم بيركز بحاله من التوتر
بيهدر الكثير من الطاقه لما يسترخي
بيستجمع الكثير من الطاقه طب احنا لما
نحكي عن الراحه ضروره الراحه لحتى تاني
يوم يكون مزاجنا
يعني جيد وعالي ونقدر انه ننتج هل نتحدث
عن راحه ذهنيه ام راحه جسديه الراحه
الذهنيه اهم من الراحه الجسديه المهم
الراحه الجسديه بس لما الذهن بيكون بخير
فالدماغ بيصدر اوامر للجسم انك انت بخير
فبيطلق هرمونات راحه وسعاده الجسم لما
ننام نحن اذا نمنا فهو تجديد الخلايا يحدث
بس احيانا اذا الواحد نام وهو قلق شو اللي
بصير بنام نوم سطحي ما بفوت بطبقات النوم
العميقه اللي تحدث خلالها تجديد الخلايا
فيعني راحه الزهن والاستمتاع وخالط الناس
اللي بنحبهم التركيز على اشياء بعيده عن
العمل لما انا اركز بشيء بعيد عن العمل
بيعتقد جهازي العصبي اني بخير
فبتطلع الهرمونات السعاده والطمانينه
ايمان حسن مدربه الحياه تقول لكم ارتاحوا
ولو عاشوا دقائق على الاقل وانت وانت
رايحه الان بعد هذه الفقره في زميلتنا
اشواق وفريق الاعداد لازم تقول لهم واحنا
على الموجز يخلونا ننام انا بدي اقلب بس
خذوا نفس عميق انا حسيت انه الانفاس قصيره
حولي فالنفس العميق بحد ذاته
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لمتابعتي المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات